♪
>> Tucker: SPORTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE REFUGE FROM
POLITICS IN MODERN AMERICA
THAT'S NOT ALLOW YOU HAD.
SOMEONE IS ALWAYS DETERMINED
TO MAKE EVERY ASPECT OF LIFE
A PC HELL HOLE.
THE STANLEY CUP FINALS ARE
BEING JOINS US TO RESPOND
TONIGHT.
DAVE, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> ALWAYS GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> YOU HAVE THERE THE
CONTROVERSIAL TOWEL, I CAN
SEE THAT'S A VERY SEXIST
TOWEL.
>> IT SAYS PUCKS ON NET,
TUCKER.
THAT IS MY PHRASE TO SCORE
GOALS TO SHOOT PUCKS ON NET.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAD A
PROBLEM WITH THIS WITH OUR
COMPANY OUT OF IT.
WE WERE NOT GOING OUT OF THE
WAY SALES GUY CALLED ME UP
WE NEED A SPONSOR FOR THE
TOWEL ARE YOU INTERESTED?
I SAID SOUNDS GOOD ALL OUR
FANS LOVE THE BRUINS, THEY
LOVE HOCKEY.
HALF THE PLAYERS IN THE
LEAGUE WE HAVE WORKED WITH.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH EVERY
LEAGUE IN THE LEAGUE.
NUMBER ONE NHL PODCAST IN
THE WORLD SEEMED LIKE A
NATURAL FIT WIN-WIN FOR
EVERYBODY.
I THOUGHT.
BUT THE PC COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WATCH
HOCKEY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST MAD AT
LIFE I HAD A QUOTE I READ
FROM 2011 WHICH REMAINS
TRUE.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE LIFE
LAUGH, THEY DON'T LIKE TO
LAUGH, THEY DON'T LIKE FUN,
THEY DON'T LIKE MEN.
THEY DON'T LIKE AMERICA.
THOSE PEOPLE THEY HATED
THIS.
THEY ABSOLUTELY HATED IT.
THEY PULLED THEIR HAIR OUT.
THEY DEMANDED ANSWERS FROM
THE BRUINS.
TURNED INTO WORLD WAR III.
A LOT OF GOOD PRESS FOR US.
I DON'T CARE ANY PRESS IS
GOOD PRESS.
IF SOMEBODY READS THIS AND
HAS A BRAIN LIKE WHO ARE
THESE GUYS SPONSORING LIKES
HOCKEY AND FUN AND THEN YOU
BECOME A BARSTOOL FAN.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE IS A WAY TO KNOW THIS
BUT OF THE MEMBERS THAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED.
>> NO FUN CLUB.
>> Tucker: PC COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY GAMES DO
THEY WATCH A YEAR.
>> OVER UNDER 5.5.
SOME REPORTERS WHO COVER THE
TEAM THAT GOT MAD.
PEOPLE PILING ON SAYING I'M
THE CLAN AND THIS AND THAT.
THOSE PEOPLE DON'T WATCH
HOCKEY.
THEY NEVER HEARD OF US.
SERIAL PROTESTERS AND FUN
KILLERS AND DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE MAD ABOUT.
WHAT CAN I GET MAD ABOUT
TODAY?
THIS TOWEL?
THIS TOWEL IS --
>> Tucker: VERY SEXIST
TOWEL.
IT'S THE MOST BASIC TOWEL IN
THE HISTORY OF TOWELS.
THEY DO IT EVERY GAME.
THERE IS BANKS, EVERYTHING.
>> Tucker: WOULDN'T IT JUST
BE EASIER TO SAY TO THE NO
FUN COMMUNITY YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU ARE IN CHARGE.
I'M SO SORRY.
I HATE MYSELF FOR MY SEXISM.
I WILL DO BETTER NEXT TIME?
>> NO.
WELL, LET THEM WIN?
AND THE THING IS IT DIDN'T
SURPRISE ME THEY GET MAD.
THEY GET MAD ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
WE STAY TO WHAT WE DO.
WE CONTINUE TO GET BIGGER.
WE CONTINUE TO GET STRONGER
AND ALL THESE PEOPLE THE
FACES CHANGE BUT THEY HAVE
FREELANCE JOBS BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WIN BY JUST
COMPLAINING ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
IF I COMPLAINED AS MUCH AS
THEY DID, I WOULD DROWN IN
MY OWN TEARS.
I JUST MOVE ON.
AND THEN THEY -- ANOTHER
THING THEY WILL DO THEY WILL
SAY PEOPLE ARE SAYING MEAN
THINGS TO US ON TWITTER.
YOU CALLED ME A NAZI AND
PEOPLE WHO LIKE ME ARE LIKE
THAT'S MEAN YOU SHOULDN'T DO
THAT GUESS WHAT?
I GET THE MEANEST THINGS
EVER SAID ABOUT ME I'M SURE
DO YOU, TOO.
>> Tucker: I HAVE, YEAH.
>> IF I SAT AND WORRIED AND
COMPLAINED AND SAID OH ME,
ME, ME.
YOU ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT ME
I WOULD GET NOTHING DONE.
THESE PEOPLE WHAT DO THEY DO
WITH THEIR LIVES.
ONE LADY, ONE REPORTER WHO
WROTE A HORRIBLE ARTICLE
ABOUT US.
SHE SAID OH I'M GETTING
ATTACKED BY THE BARSTOOL
PEOPLE SEE THIS IS WHAT THEY
DO.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY TWEETS
SHE HAD FIVE?
WE HAVE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS AND FOLLOWERS.
FIVE PEOPLE SAID YOU WROTE A
BAD ARTICLE YOU?
ARE GOING TO CRY ABOUT THAT?
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
>> Tucker: SHE ATTACKS YOU
BUT SHE IS THE VICTIM.
>> CORRECT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ALL DO.
THERE IS NO WAY AROUND IT.
WE ARE A BIG POPULAR
ORGANIZATION.
WE HAVE LOYAL RABID FANS
WHICH HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING US
FOR 15 YEARS.
KNOW OUR TRUE CULTURE.
KNOW WHAT WE STAND ABOUT.
IF YOU SAY I'M A SCUM BAG
THEY TAKE THAT AS A PERSONAL
OFFENSE.
IT'S BANANAS.
THEY TWEET IT IN PUBLIC.
IT'S A PUBLIC FORUM THAT
THEY SAY THEY HATE ME AND
THEN IF SOMEONE SAYS GUESS
WHAT YOU?
ARE THE SCUM BAG THEY CRY OH
POOR ME, POOR ME.
JUST SHUT UP.
WORRY ABOUT YOURSELF.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT US.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE TOWEL,
DON'T PICK IT UP.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
THIS IS A SALES DEAL.
THE BRUINS HAVE BEEN
SPONSORED BY BANKS, HUGE
ORGANIZATIONS.
DO YOU THINK THAT THERE IS
NOT BAD STUFF?
THIS STORY I WILL TELL
QUICK.
ONE GUY WHO WROTE AND THIS
IS A TRUE STORY, TUCKER A
GUY FROM ST. LOUIS WROTE A
STORY HOW THE BRUINS SHOULD
BE ASHAMED HE WAS ARRESTED
FOR ROBBING A BANK.
IS HE A BANK ROBBER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THIS GUY IS A LEGITIMATE
BANK ROBBER.
>> Tucker: NO FUN COMMUNITY,
PC COMMUNITY AND BANK